c'est la prise en charge nous avons
emmené l'animal chez un vétérinaire
voilà on a le compte rendu du
vétérinaire
aussi et oreilles très sale très mauvais
état général maigre il était il avait il
était pas nourri ce soir il avait aussi
des problèmes de de déshydratation aussi
très grand nombre de cicatrices sur le
crâne le corps il est pas
plie joue droite circulaire pouvant être
des traces de brûlures de cigarette plie
entre les yeux et ma tombe de 10 cm de
diamètre sur le haut du crâne
œdème des deux joues suspicion de
fractures du genou gauche il avait une
ancienne fracture de la patte avant
gauche avec formation
d'un problème au courant c'est ça
fracture du doigt 3 et 4 de la pâte
avant droite fracture des deux
mandibules suspicion d'une fracture du
crâne en retard de l'hématome à confirmé
par un scanner
fracture de la hanche gauche fracture
ancienne des côtes 8 9